let's say that you are desperate for a
dollar and so you come to me the local
loan shark and you say hey i need to
borrow a dollar for a year and i tell
you well you know i'm in a good mood i'm
willing to lend you that dollar that you
need for a year and i will lend it to
you for the low interest of 100 percent
per year
so 100 percent
so how much would you have to pay me in
a year where you're going to have to pay
the original principal what i let you
plus 100 of that so plus
one other dollar which is clearly going
to be equal to
clearly going to be equal to two dollars
now you say well gee that's a lot to
have to pay to have to have to have to
pay back twice what i borrowed and
there's a possibility that i might have
the money in six months what kind of a
deal can you get me for that mr loan
shark and i say oh gee if you're willing
to pay back in six months then i'll just
charge you half the interest for half
the time so
you borrow
one dollar and so in six months
in six months
i will charge you 50 interest
fifty percent interest
over six
over six months this of course was one
one year
and so how much would you have to pay
well you would have to pay the original
principal what you borrowed the one
dollar plus 50 percent of that one
dollar so plus
0.50 and that of course is equal to 1.5
so that is equal to or a dollar fifty
i'll just write it like this a dollar
fifty now you say well gee that's i
guess better but what happens if i don't
have the money then if i still actually
need a year
and i say well we actually have a system
for that what i'll do is just say that
okay you don't have the money for me yet
i'll essentially we can think about it
that i'll just lend that amount that you
need for you for another six months
so we'll lend that out
we'll lend that out for another six
months at the same interest rate at 50
for the next
six months and so then you'll owe me
you'll owe me the principal a dollar
fifty
a dollar fifty
plus fifty percent of the principal plus
seventy five cents
plus 75 cents and that gets us to 2
dollars and 25 cents
so that equals
2.25 cents or another way of thinking
about it
is to go from one dollar over the first
period you just multiply that times 1.5
if you're going to grow something by 50
percent you just multiply it times 1.5
and if you're going to grow it by
another 50 percent you can multiply by
1.5 again so one way of thinking about
is that 50 interest is the same thing as
multiplying by 1.5 multiplying by 1.5 so
if you start with 1 and multiply 1.5
multiply by 1.5 twice
this is going to be the same thing
2.25 is going to be 1 multiplied by 1.5
twice
1.5
multiplied twice is the same thing as
1.5 squared and you can see the same
thing right over here this is the same
thing
100 percent is the same thing as
multiplying as multiplying by two as
literally multiplying by one plus one so
this is multiplying by two so you could
view this right over here
you could view this as one
times one one times one
to the first
one sorry one times two i should say one
times two to the first power because
you're only doing it over one period
over that year and you say once again
where is that two well if someone's
asking for a hundred percent that means
over the period you're gonna have to pay
twice you have to pay the principal plus
a hundred percent you have to pay twice
what you originally borrowed if
someone's charging you fifty percent
over every period you're going to have
to pay whatever you borrowed so that's
kind of the one part plus 50 of it so
1.5 times what you borrowed so you
multiply times 1.5 every time and if you
wanted to see how this actually related
to the interest you could view this as
so this right over here is equal to
one
times
times the interest part is one plus
one hundred percent
divided by one period to the first power
and i know this seems like a crazy way
of just trying rewriting what we just
wrote over here writing one plus one but
you'll see that we can keep writing this
as we compound over different periods
this one right over here we can rewrite
you can write as one
times
one plus one hundred percent here we
took our hundred percent for the year we
divided it into two periods two six
month periods each of them at fifty
percent one plus hundred percent over
two is the same thing as one point five
and then we compounded it we compounded
it over two periods and actually let me
do that two periods into a different
color so this
the periods let me do in this orange
color right over here and you might
start to see a pattern forming so let's
say well gee maybe i have the money back
in and you don't really like this
because this is 2.25 that was more than
the original two dollars so you say well
what if i if we do this over every 12
months i say sure we got a program for
that
so after every 12 months after every 12
after every month i should say
i'm just going to charge you i'm going
to charge you 100
divided by 12 uh interest so this is
equal to 8 and 1 third
percent and taking and or or get taking
the having to pay back the principal
plus eight and one-third percent that's
the same thing as multiplying times
1.083
repeating so after one month you would
have to pay
1.083 repeating
after two months after two months and
this isn't to scale that actually looks
more like more than two months but it's
not completely at scale after two months
you're gonna have to multiply by this
again so times 1.083
repeating and so that would get you to
1.083
repeating
squared and if you went all the way down
12 months so let me get myself some
space here so if you went all the way
down 12 months
so let me just
so 12 months
or i say from the beginning 12 months so
another 10 months
so what's the total interest you would
have to pay over a year if you weren't
able to keep coming up with the money if
you had to keep reborrowing and i kept
compounding that interest
well you're going to have to pay
1.083
to the well this is for one month so you
could view this as to the first power
this is for two months so you're gonna
have to pay this to the 12th power we
have compounded over 12 periods eight
and one-third percent over 12 periods or
if you wanted to write it in this form
right over here
this would be the same thing as our
original principle
our original principle times
times one
one plus one hundred percent
divided by twelve
so now we've divided our 100 into 12
periods and we're going to compound that
12 times
so we're going to take that to the
take that to the 12th power so what is
this going to equal to this business
right over here so we can get a
calculator out for that
so get my ti-85 out and so what is this
going to be equal to well we could do it
a couple of ways and this is 1.083 let
me write you this is repeating
right over here let's get our calculator
out so we can do it a couple of ways
actually let me just write it this way
you're going to get the same value and i
don't have to rewrite this one here i
just did that there to kind of hopefully
you see this the kind of structure in
this expression so 1 plus 100 is the
same thing as one so one divided by
twelve
to the twelfth power
to the twelfth power two point six one
three i'll just round so approximately
approximately 2.613
now you say well this is an interesting
game you've almost forgot about your
financial troubles and you're just
intrigued by what happens if we keep
going this if we you know here we
compounded just we have 100 over a year
here we do 50 every six months here we
do a twelfth of a hundred percent eight
and one third percent every 12 months we
get to this number well what happens if
we did it every day
every day so five bar to one dollar and
i said well yeah gee i'm just gonna each
day i'm just gonna charge you i'm just
gonna charge you
one three hundred sixty-fifth of a
hundred percent
so a hundred percent
divided by 365 and i'm going to compound
that
365 times and so you're you're curious
mathematically and you say well what do
we get then what do we get what do we
get after a year well you have your
original principle let me scroll over a
little bit more to the right so we have
more space
you're going to have your original
principle
times
1 plus 100
divided by not 12. now we've divided 100
into 365 periods
365 periods
and but we're going to compound it
remember every time we have to multiply
by 1 plus 100 over 365 every day that
the loan is not paid so the 365th
365th power you say oh gee you know
taking something of the 365th power
that's going to give me some huge number
but then you say well actually maybe not
so bad because 100 divided by 365 is
going to be a small number this thing is
going to be reasonably close to one and
obviously we could raise one to whatever
power we want and we don't get anything
crazy so let's see where this one goes
let's see where this one goes so this is
the same thing as 1 plus 100 is the same
thing as 1 divided by 365
to the 365
power
and we get
2.71456
let me let me put it over here so then
we get
so this is approximately equal to
approximately equal to two and you know
this approximate is a very it's it's a
very precise approximation but two point
seven but my calculator's precision is
is only goes so far two point seven 1 4
5 6 7 5 and it keeps going on and on and
this is really really interesting it
looks like as we take larger and larger
numbers here it doesn't just balloon
into just some crazy ginormous number it
seems to be approaching some magical and
mystical number and it is in fact the
case that if you were to just take
larger and larger if you were to take
your 100 and divide by larger and larger
numbers but take it to that power you're
going to approach perhaps the most
magical and mystical number of all the
number e and you could see it right over
here on your calculator they have this
this e to the x and i can do that so e
to the i'll raise it to the first power
so you can look at the calculator's
internal representation of it and you
see just already raising some doing 1
plus 1 over 365 to 365th power we got
pretty we got we're starting to get
really really really really close to e
and i encourage you to try this with
larger and larger numbers and you're
going to get closer and closer to this
magical mr you almost wouldn't mind
paying the loan shark e dollars because
it's such a beautiful number